how are you guys good PDG was that's a
new Diablo pretty damn good oh pretty
damn good great darn good oh sorry we're
done Haneda you can say damn I didn't
you can say whatever you want throw one
out right now we can put on TV rat and
put that on TV who don't want out we can
put on TV you what is you before we go
what is your life like if you do have a
handle on your life right now oh sure
really yeah what do you mean coz I don't
know what it would be like I don't think
regular people would know what it would
be like to be in the middle of that as
it is when you walk onto a carpet or
when you walk well that's that's part of
the job that's that's like leaving work
at the office yeah that's my office yeah
never had carpet is my office this
studio is my office and you leave it
there and you go home and you have your
real life your normal life and you
surround yourself with people who are
really genuine yeah and it's not that
hard to do yeah I saw it you saw what's
that like well I I mean I've never seen
anything like that yeah I'm done with
her and all taking the group shots yeah
I can just tell you is from like an
outsider point of view it's insane I
mean you probably are used to it now and
that seems like reality but it's like
that that whole world right there just
that carpet is I just it's it was freaky
to me it was scary cuz I had I don't
know how you do that
you numb yourself to the natural is that
what it is do you know if you do you
name yourself to I don't know if there's
every I don't know if there's a man
alive who's not in love with you in some
way you're so silly you know what I'm I
am I really
you're silly no I'm not I am NOT Wow
Wow you have to go into every situation
when you have a conversation with a man
you've never met that is going to end at
some point with him flirting with you no
absolutely not Johnny's never flirted
with me once he's been flirting the
whole time we've been saying this is my
freakin age I'm bringing out first
string right now have you not picked
that up showing my dimples here hard
really you don't I'm exhausted
I don't socialize without many people so
maybe that's what it is I just sort of
lock myself away I'm a recluse yeah you
know I think you're flirting as me I'm
kidding
totally kidding come on watch this okay
Amanda totally just busted you guys tell
me about going to a strip joint when you
first met oh dude for real is it not
true at all is it true really
it's not true you're such a liar were
you there cuz I wasn't there she said
you were leading the charge and you had
all the money oh I do have all the money
[Music]
what were you just saying we weren't
there
she might have been there were there
maybe some other people that I wasn't I
lost I was in my room every night like
eight o'clock eight thirty eight o'clock
eight thirty go to bed carry vampire
person I'm in my I'm not kidding ask
everyone that knows me
like that you know a little bit